FTX
Celsius block Phi a wave of bankruptcies
is hitting the crypto industry and
policy makers are calling for regulation
regulatory framework we really need to
make sure that that environment has the
appropriate regulatory guard rails to
find out how Washington might regulate
the crypto industry moving forward let's
look at a few past SEC investigations
that reveal how the agency sees crypto
in 2020 the SEC sued cryptocurrency
company Ripple over the company's coin
xrp it is by far the biggest piece of
litigation that the SEC has against a
cryptocurrency the agency charged two
Rebel Executives with engaging in an
illegal Securities offering by selling
xrp the agency argued that it wasn't a
currency it was a security making the
distinction using the Securities Act of
1933. the law says that if something is
an investment contract or one form of a
security it can be regulated under this
act but the courts didn't clarify what
that was until a Supreme Court case in
1946. to call something an investment
contract it has to pass a test aptly
named the Howie test there's just three
questions
first has someone invested money then is
there a common Enterprise is the success
of the buyer intertwined with the seller
and third is the buyer led to expect
profits derived from others if all the
answers are yes it's a security the
Ripple lawsuit says you know the SEC are
holding the ground and insisting that
this whole new world of crypto is really
just a new form of the same old function
which is to issue a kind of an asset in
order to raise money to build a business
but some crypto companies like Ripple
don't accept this idea they say their
products aren't Securities they're
Commodities like gold they say that
digital assets with a real world purpose
don't trade because of the seller there
is no common Enterprise so the tokens
aren't Securities Ripple said the SEC
was acting outside their legal limits
and they would continue to fight the
case in September both parties filed
motions asking a federal judge to render
a verdict with this case the SEC took
its biggest shot at broadly establishing
its jurisdiction over the crypto market
then a year later the SEC took the same
law and applied it to a new part of the
industry crypto lending it started
investigating block thigh a platform
that allowed users to loan crypto to
others for trading blockfy was doing
something that the SEC had not yet
enforced against and the SEC said that
that transaction that offering that
blocked that I was doing was also an
investment contract which is a form of a
security for the case the agency's
reasoning was this the way blockwise
product worked is that it borrowed
crypto assets from customers with the
promise to repay it with interest that
fast easy said counted as investment of
money blockfi would lend those assets to
institutional borrowers and keep some
profits for itself there's common
Enterprise and based on block 5
statements about paying interest the
company LED investors to expect profit
so blockvis crypto lending accounts
passed the Howie test making it in the
sec's eyes a security the SEC moving
into trying to regulate a crypto lending
products
shows you that a lot of this crypto
ecosystem resembles traditional finance
and the SEC therefore is going to look
at that and say
that looks like the kind of thing we
regulate blockfy settled for 100 million
dollars the highest fine ever agreed to
by a cryptocurrency company block 5 CEO
Zach Prince said the company cooperated
with Regulators we have a long history
of compliance and working with
regulators and this is another example
of that block fi which filed for
bankruptcy in November did not reply to
a request for comment but the case
expanded the sec's use of the Howie test
to regulate crypto showing the agency
was willing to Target non-traditional
digital assets then later in 2022 the
agency took aim at a different part of
the industry celebrity endorsements
though don't mean that an investment
product is right for you or even frankly
that it's legitimate
the SEC was Prosecuting celebrities for
advertising crypto
for example let's look at the agency's
recent action against Kim Kardashian
in September 2021 Kardashian posted a
video and swipe up story on Instagram
promoting ethereum Max tokens and was
paid 250 000 for the Post
the SEC said that because ethereum Max
was a security with you guessed it an
investment of money common Enterprise
and a reasonable expectation of profits
the agency argued that Kardashians post
should be regulated under another part
of the Securities act that said she
couldn't advertise a security without
revealing that ethereum Max paid her the
SEC fined her over a million dollars for
the lack of disclosure Kardashian did
not respond to a request for comment in
these cases because they they involve
celebrities they allow the SEC to
amplify their message to a much broader
audience
than the sec's enforcement actions
typically reach the cases against Ripple
blockfi and Kardashian show the sec's
strategy for applying Securities
regulations to crypto the SEC is going
to continue to apply
these laws to crypto unless and until
Congress decides that crypto should fall
under its own sort of customized
regulatory regime the SEC said in May it
would add 20 new investigators to its
crypto unit but if regulations changed
some of the crypto Market could fall
under the commodity Futures Trading
commission the sec's sister agency we
are going to continue to see a lot of
the same kinds of enforcement actions
but we don't know yet if the strategy is
going to change somehow because of what
happened with FTX but it's likely the
agency will continue on the path of
enforcement in the future
foreign